hey it's me again in this video we're
going to show you the vital importance
of the gallbladder
now the gallbladder is probably the most
ignored downgraded part of your body
doctors say you don't need it it's an
extra order for birth but it's the most
common thing that I find and if you have
a gallbladder problem we need to show
you how to reverse it and undo it okay
so we're going to show you what it is
what it means if there's a problem how
to identify the problem what causes the
problem and what to do about it okay so
the first thing is that you have this
liver right here it's three and a half
pounds of size of a football it's on the
right side upper underneath the right
ribcage and then it has a little tube
that goes into a little sac called the
gallbladder
so the gallbladder is just a sac it
holds something called bile bile is made
by the liver and bile is like the
detergent that breaks down the grease
it's a fluid that the liver makes the
help dissolves dissolve fat so when you
eat fat it signals the gallbladder to
squeeze and contract this stored bile
into the small intestine so you can
actually break down dietary fat into
smaller particles now it does get help
from the pancreas so the pancreas makes
a bunch of enzymes so you got this bile
and enzymes that start to go in there
and start dissolving the fats into tiny
little particles so you can use those
fatty acids which are very beneficial to
your health to build tissue cells brain
nerve etc so let's just take a look at
some of the cool things that the bile
will do it will help you absorb fat
soluble vitamins what's a fats I have a
vitamin it's a very unique type of
vitamin that has the capacity to be
stored in fat and the capacity to go
through the cell wall a lot of the fat
Seibel vitamins especially vitamin D and
vitamin A act at like hormones to your
body so they're not really even like a
vitamin they're like hormones so they're
very very important in tool to create a
lot of effects I'm going to show you
that but when you eat vegetables
vegetables don't have they have the pre
vitamins
so they have a pre vitamin a pre vitamin
K a true vitamin a active form is only
an animal product so when you eat
vegetarian vegetables and things like
that you're only getting a very small
percentage maybe 4% of that vitamin that
converts to the active form but here's
the thing if you're deficient in vitamin
A you'll get night blindness it's hard
to see in the dark
you get dry eyes dry skin a lot of skin
issues will happen from that so that's a
vitamin A deficiency but see if you have
this it could be not that you're not
necessarily like not eating vitamin A it
could because you don't have the bile to
digest the vitamin A that you're eating
already so we have to see the change of
a reaction that occurs all the way
across and identify what the problem is
okay so if the person is like eating a
lot of butter for example that's in
vitamin A that's vitamins of vitamin A
and butter and but they still have like
night blindness dries then we know we
have to add the bile okay so it's just a
way of kind of figuring things out now
let's take a look at vitamin d3 like
who's deficient in d3 like half the
population what is what happens when you
get deficiency to vitamin d3 you get
depression especially in the winter it's
called the blues also you have chronic
fatigue syndrome is a vitamin D
deficiency flu you get flu symptoms
because the immune factors a lot of
autoimmune diseases can kick in from low
vitamin D because the immune factor if
you take a look at when does the flu
kick in it's usually in the fall when
there's no Sun right a lot of issues
even polio occurred more in the fall a
lot of viruses come out of remission in
the fall and it's because of this
vitamin D drop after the summer so
you've got the flu achy joints well that
could be symptoms of the flu to bone
pain that could be symptoms of the flu
high blood pressure because one of the
remedies for high blood pressure is
taking vitamin D respiratory like asthma
kids that have asthma don't have asthma
symptoms if they're out in the Sun
allergies and asthma
psoriasis that's the skin issue a lot of
vitamin D will help this muscle cramps
and calf so you need vitamin D why would
that be affected because it transports
it helps to absorb calcium in the
intestine so vitamin D helps you absorb
calcium into the blood from the small
intestine so it allows the increased
absorption of calcium by 20 times if you
donate vitamin D you would have 20 times
less calcium so that's what vitamin D
does so if you have these symptoms but
you're taking vitamin D it could be
because you don't have enough bile all
right now vitamin k2 that's different
than vitamin k1
all right vitamin k1 is about clotting
if you have bruising you could be
deficient vitamin k1 but k2 is different
vitamin k2 is a transport calcium
transport vitamin so when you're
deficient in k2 you get a lot of calcium
that builds up in the soft tissues of
the body so you get arthritis tendonitis
bursitis you get calcium in the arteries
it that's why the blood pressure goes up
that's why you get heart attacks calcium
on the eyes that's a cataract kidney
stones strokes why because there's
calcium and plaquing in the brain
arteries of the brain Alzheimer's
because of the calcium buildup so also
deficient in k2 will cause you to have
osteoporosis because vitamin d3
increases the calcium but it doesn't
tell it where to go k2 takes the calcium
and drives it where it should go out of
where it should not be so so many people
have this calcium that's plugging up
their entire body as they get older they
they go into a stone the huge
recommendation for the elderly and most
the baby boomers was to avoid fat right
they're going to starve the body of k2
by a vitamin k2 is in butter eggs it's
in all the grass-fed beef it's in
grass-fed animal products okay so look
at that I mean look at how many problems
occur because
someone doesn't have enough bile and
correct it's crazy so you really need to
make sure these are in the diet and make
sure this works now let's take a look at
the thyroid 80% of the thyroid function
is converted through the liver so t4 is
converted to the liver and t4 just
represents the number of iodine
molecules to that thyroid hormone so the
bile strips off an iodine into t3 t3 is
the active form of thyroid hormone so t4
doesn't do anything the body unless it
converts at t3 and guess what 80% of it
occurs through the bile ducts in the
liver so here the person has is taking
thyroid medication they don't have a
thyroid gland anymore or they have
thyroid symptoms dry hair loss of
eyebrows slow metabolism but in fact it
could be they don't have enough file to
convert t4 to t3 so we have to look at
the broad spectrum some other symptoms
to identify low bile would be
constipation why because bile acts as a
lubricant to your colon bloating burping
belching is a sign of congestive gall
bladder right shoulder pain because
there's a nerve on the right side that
goes all the way up to the right
shoulder and it could be the neck it
could be headaches right shoulder right
scapula right trap anyone on the right
it can't even pinch a nerve here and
cause pain down the right arm also
another sign would be not satisfied
after you eat so here you are you to
food but you still need a little
something something it just doesn't
really do anything it's because you
don't have the bio to absorb the fatty
acids to pull them into the brain this
is huge this is important okay so now
what we the cause of a bio problem one
is high levels of cortisol that's from
the adrenal that's a stress hormone so
stress can shut down your bile ducts and
that's the duct that comes through here
estrogen can do it that's why a lot of
women end up with a gall bladder problem
after pregnancy because the high levels
of estrogen that can occur so estrogen
could destroy the gall bladder too and
even from hormone replacement therapy
birth control pills or just having high
estrogen which we'll cover in another
video which is basically like your pure
Hevy crampy irregular periods that's
high estrogen and that will block the
gallbladder low fat diets will cause
gall bladder problems so you know
vegetarians that go off all saturated
fats well then there's nothing to
trigger the goal butter so it dries up
so you don't have any bile and you can't
digest fat so that's why your lot of
experience have dry skin they're just
dry inside and out it's because low fat
so we want to increase the healthy fats
soy protein isolates that's in all the
diet foods that's in all the prepackaged
soy patties that you get Morningstar
it's in a lot of the diets the with the
diet out there Medifast Nutrisystem when
I was Ideal Protein they all used soy
protein isolates cheap crappy protein
real hard in the gallbladder it'll cause
tumors and liver and destroy the gall
butter other than that is perfectly fine
that was my dry sense of humor junk food
will also do it okay so that is the
significance of liver now now that you
know the effects of what that will
create if you have a problem in how to
identify it now what do we do about it
number one we're going to show you in
the next part how to do acupressure to
the gallbladder in the pancreas so
you're going to do that to yourself
you're going to change your diet you're
going to get off the sugar and have
healthy fats to start triggering this
combination of acupressure there are
some great supplements too to give you
more bile because you're deficient to
get the ball rolling because see bile is
recycled and if you lose it sometimes it
takes a long time to get it back so this
will give you the bile back preview.i
bile salts so you can start using it if
you had your gallbladder out then you
definitely need the gallbladder formula
because the gallbladder formula has bile
salts it has enzymes from the pancreas
lick called lipase to digest the fats so
we have pancreatic support and gall
there support right together and another
thing for the stomach called betaine
hydrochloride to help the stomach the
gallbladder the pancreas helps lubricate
the colon it's the ultimate gallbladder
support formula and you would take
start off with taking one at breakfast
okay and then see how it goes and then
take one for lunch if you needed a one
for dinner until you feel really less
bloated in there so this is really
important if you take too much bowel you
might have a little diarrhea so if you
have diarrhea you should never take this
right here because that could be could
mean when they let's say you took your
gallbladder out the tube could be too
big now and it just drains right out
even though you might your livers
producing like crazy it's just going
through at a higher level so anyway just
want to use the diam that is an
indicator to know that you're taking
either too much but no more normally
people will be fine with that
the only contraindication let's see take
all better formula and you get heartburn
what that means
since gallbladder formula is very
alkaline and your let's say your stomach
is already too alkaline then it could
like create some heartburn because your
body is trying to compensate if that
happens then you would stop taking this
and switch to something called betaine
hydrochloride and and that's just a side
note that's rare but you might need to
do that because betaine hydrochloride is
just acid and that will actually get
your stomach more acid so then you don't
really need this because it'll one of
the triggers for gallbladder is stomach
acid being very acid so if you don't
have enough ass in your stomach it means
that you're never going to basically
release the bile so if you take the pain
hunter cord that should solve that
problem but don't worry about that
unless you have that problem
cruciferous food why because the liver
does really well on cruciferous food
products I have a supplement called
cruciferous food that you can take that
actually has all of the cruciferous and
some serious vegetables to help
roto-rooter and clean the liver out and
restore liver function so that's a row
of something that I recommend on a
regular basis and of course eat they'll
eat those foods as well now to take you
the d3 and the k2 I have a lot of people
on those two right now especially to
clean up all the intracellular or organ
soft tissue calcium in the body it's
good for so many issues and also to
prevent
strokes personally I take 4d 3 & 4 k2
every morning sometimes depending if you
have these problems you can take a
little bit more I would take a 1:1 ratio
and then if you don't have this problem
let's say you're you're a little younger
and you don't have an issue just take
one of each
they're already built in this is 10,000
IU's and this is the right ratio of k2
some people freak out because oh my gosh
that's high vitamin d3 well 10 thousand
international units there's only one
milligram of d3 so it's really not that
much and then the last thing is the DHA
the DHA is a healthy fat that's really
good for memory and Alzheimer's and I
also take that one because of the what
it does to your brain it actually fixes
your brain it's really good for
sharpness and that's a really important
one then if you take the gallbladder you
can really emulsify and break that down
so I hope now you have a more awareness
of what's happening with the gallbladder
the consequences of having a gallbladder
issue and you can think backwards of the
symptoms of this the causes and then
what to do so in the next section we're
going to show you the acupressure so now
we know you'll know how to do the
acupressure to your own gallbladder and
pancreas you know what foods you'll be
on with the eating and you know what
nutrition you need to do to undo it ok
so I hope that helps